los senadores estadounidenses acordaron
una medida provisional para evitar el
impago con un compromiso a corto plazo
propuesto por los republicanos hemos
llegado a un acuerdo para prorrogar el
techo de la deuda hasta principios de
septiembre y tenemos la esperanza de que
podamos dejar esto hecho hoy mismo el
límite de la deuda se prorroga hasta el
3 de diciembre y se incrementa en 480
mil millones de dólares pero aunque el
acuerdo da un respiro al gobierno no
resuelve la crisis los legisladores
tienen unas siete semanas para limar sus
diferencias sobre el gasto centradas en
el plan de política social bilbao ver de
joe biden ya hace meses que los
republicanos insisten en que los
demócratas deben ser los únicos que
asuman la responsabilidad de aumentar el
techo de la deuda a través del proceso
de reconciliación pero los demócratas
sostienen que el proceso es demasiado
arriesgado y complejo al respecto el
líder de la minoría del senado mitch
mcconnell se mantiene firme
y la vida que han aceptado nuestros
colegas demócratas evitará al pueblo
estadounidense cualquier crisis a corto
plazo y acabará definitivamente con la
excusa de la mayoría de que le falta
tiempo para abordar el límite de la
deuda a través del proceso de
reconciliación ahora no habrá dudas
tendrán tiempo de sobra
desde que el congreso estableció el
límite de la deuda en 1939 se ha
aumentado más de 100 veces normalmente
con apoyo bipartidista pero en los
últimos años se ha convertido en una
cuestión política utilizada para
perjudicar al partido en el poder